bunu çocukken oynadığımız bir oyun vardı
bu saklambaça eş değer bir şeydir
endotura 1-2-3 deriz arkaya bakarız ve
giderek bize doğru Gelirler ya o oyun
Bu oyun Aslında Fransızca'dan geliyormuş
önünde Tura da zaten hani
önde Truva diye okunuyor herhalde
Fransızca bitirmiş bunu öğrendiğimde çok
şok oldum yani
bazı şeyleri hayatta o kadar var kabul
ediyoruz ki yani ve hiç sorgulamıyoruz
ki hatta bizim kuşakta arada davul zurna
da vardı
bugün inşallah size onu anlatmaya
çalışacağım her şey sorgulamak yani
eğitim sistemi için söylüyorum o kadar
çok şeyi zaten var diye kabul ediyoruz
ki onları sorgulamak hiçbir zaman
aklımıza gelmiyor
Şimdi benim Reklamcılık mesleği için
söylüyorum Ankara'da 2 yıl geçirdim
babası bayıldığı için her yerde Gezdik
Yani memleketteki bütün Anadolu
liselerinde bir iki yılımı harcamışımdır
hemen hemen Kıbrıs'ta zaman geçirdim
Erzurum'da Çorlu'da bu toplumda neler
olduğunu anlamaya dair Aslında güzel bir
fikir veriyor Dolayısıyla mesela yaşanan
çoğu şeyde Biz İstanbul'dan
Nişantaşı'nda otururken her şeye
şaşırıyor arkadaşlarımla hiç
şaşırmıyorum Ben anlıyorum bir sürü
arkadaşım oldu Ve bu çok büyük avantaj
bu arada Adana'ya da ilk defa geliyor
Neyse Evet yani böyle bir şuraya kadar
televizyon programları yazdım
şu Murat dişli diye bir çocuktur bu MR
beep de bizim yazar grubumuz vardı bu
şimdi Bir kadın bir erkeği yazıyor ya da
sanırım bitti galiba program Sonra işte
Rauf benim Varol diye bir arkadaşımız
vardı orada Erdil Yaşaroğlu vardı bir de
Burak Hakkı bunlar böyle komik komik
arkadaşlar listeden komiklik yaparak
başladık bu işe sonra
bir yandan reklam yazmaya başladım
reklamda ayrı bir güzel bir durum var
Her seferinde her şey yeniden yeniden
sorgulamanız gerekir yani bir şeyi
pazarı var olan koşullarıyla kabul
etmemeniz gerekiyor
Ben özetle inanmak içindeyim Yani çok
iyi bir inanırım ben bir fikir bulurum
ona çılgınlar gibi inanırım ona aşık
olurum O heyecanla etrafındaki
insanlarla geçer ve sonra birlikte bir
müşteriye gideriz müşteriye durumu
anlatırız onlar da heyecanlanırsa o
uydurduğunuz hayal gerçek olur yani
toplumda da bunu karşılandığı zaman
görme fırsatım oldu Ne zaman enerjimizi
düşük olsa ne zaman fitre yeterince
inanmasak o fikir güzel de olsa çöpe
gitti şimdi inanma üzerine anlatırken
sorgulama üzerine anlatırken
önemli bir süre boyunca
yüksek aklıma deniyor buna galiba yüksek
atlamayı bu şekilde atlamışlar zaten
önümüzde bir engel konu olduğunda
Hepimiz böyle atlıyoruz
Ondan sonra dik Rose bile bir adam şu
değişik acayip atlayış şekli var ya Onu
ilk defa denemiş Bu arkadaşlar çok büyük
bir cesaret ister gerçekten yanlış
yapmışım Sense şurada bile ben
heyecanlanıyorum insanlar bana bakıyor
Koskocaman bir olimpiyat stadında herkes
böyle atlarken Dur ben böyle bir şey
deneyeceğim yapma Gerçekten zor bir şey
kendisi hakikaten bakalım
çok gergin mi
Ondan sonra bu standart haline gelmeye
başlıyor bakın Biz Türkler burada çok
büyük bir hata yapıyoruz pazarda bakalım
Baksanıza Şu an şu an çok doğal olarak
algıladığımız bu şeyi Normal şartlarda o
yıllarda Yani bir yıl önce size yapsam
Ne yapıyorsun abi bu da çok doğal yani
niye böyle bir şey yapılsın yani neyse
sonuç itibariyle Adamcağız denemiş
Çoğu zaman bunu yapmak zorunda kalıyoruz
yani her zamanki reklam filmini
izlediğinizde O sizin için bir şey ifade
etmiyor Hatta şey diyorlar Bu tren
yolunun geçtiği yerlerde yaşayanlar Bunu
bilir bir müddet sonra o sesi duymamaya
başlarsın yıllardır bazı markalar beyaz
Ötesi Daha da beyaz söyle beyaz diyor ve
artık onları
duymuyorsun ne zaman ki sizi kuralı
değiştiren pazarın kurallarını
değiştiren değişik bir hareket yapılıyor
o zaman hem satış sonucu alıyoruz hem de
sorgulayan gençler yetiştirmiş oluyoruz
şimdi Düşünsenize mesela şu bilgisayarda
ben yani Ben dedim neyse Çok acıktık her
şeyi gördük yani şu bilgisayarlarda da
çok vakit geçirdik 5
renkleri değişti Yani Şuradaki
insanların herhangi birine söylesem en
çok Sevdiğiniz renk nedir desem kimse 5
demez ama yıllarca bilgisayar dediğimiz
şey bu renk
şöyle bir bilgisayar yapana kadar dedi
Düşünsenize dünyayı değiştirecek olan
adamın bu bilgisayarlara Hayır deyip
başka bir şey yapması gerekiyor zaten o
insanlar ancak dünyayı değiştirebiliyor
Yoksa olmuyor yani
Neyse bu dijital dünya ile ilgili Hani
internet hayatımıza iyice girdi
reklamcılıkla da çok değiştirdi Yani ben
kendi dizi yazdığım yılları söylüyorum
zaten hiç de Fair bir durum değildi yani
Düşünsenize birkaç arkadaşa oturup bir
senaryo yazıyoruz ve TRT'de herkes
izliyor bu Aslında doğru bir şey değil
yani şu an herkes üretiyor herkes
izliyor herkesin ürettiğini herkes
biliyor ve daha güzel bir ortam var
neyse bu dijital dünya geliyor Ben de bu
enfe turuna davul zurna 1 2 3 gibi
dijital dünyaya yaklaşıyor öğrendi ha
geldi ha geleceklerdi ve Dijital dünya
geldi arkadaşlar yani hayatımızın gayet
içerisinde var zaten bu dijital dünya
ile ilgili yıllardır bütün
akademisyenler bu konuları konuşuyorlar
mesela itti telgraf teşrif edildiğinde
diyorlar ki telgraf geldi Artık dünyaya
Barış gelecek
insanlar birbirlerini görüyorlar
birbirlerine haber veriyorsunuz
söyleseniz kimden Amerika'ya anında
habere sürebiliyorsunuz müthiş aslında
kez daha televizyon içinde öyle anında
karşılıklı konuşulabiliyor mesajlar
iletilebiliyor cep telefonları
telefonları derken Her seferinde de
iddia Şu Dünyaya artık değişiyor yepyeni
bira yepyeni bir şeye başlıyoruz bundan
sonra dünyaya Barış gelecek Barış Barış
gelmiyor arkadaşlar mesela terörist
arkadaşların elinde bu telefonlardan var
tecavüzcülerde de var profesörlerde de
var Dolayısıyla bunun dünyanın
değişmesiyle en ufak bir alakası yok
Dolayısıyla dünyayı değiştirecek olan
şey biz yani genel olarak
dünyayı değiştirecek olan şey teknoloj
i değil Neyse
bu Biz genel olarak interneti biliyoruz
zannediyoruz çoğumuz buna şey diyorlar
yani şey geziniyoruz yani Hepimiz
düşünelim Biz internete ne kattık hangi
datayı girdik bugüne kadar bizim
yazdığımızı kaç kişi okudu Yani evet
elimizde telefonlar var Çok da güzel
imkanlar var ya mesela yediğimiz yemeyi
çekip paylaşıyoruz Ama gerçekten çoğu
zaman var olan içerikleri topluyoruz
kendimiz yaratmak yerine Neyse mesela
Bakın bu Geçen gün gördüm Facebook şeysi
Rabbim tahsilatını affetsin
Hasan kardeş tahsilat değil tahsilat
eminim yazılım hatası oldu Saygılar
demiş Bir de çok saygılı bir ilişki var
arada o demiş ki Eyvallah teşekkür
ederim demiş Acar kardeş yazılım hatası
değil yazılım hatası saygılardır
sonra devam edin süper Herkes birbirinin
hatasını düzeltmiş demiş Melen Hanım
herkes değil Herkes
dolayısıyla böyle bir zincirleme isim
tamlaması başlıyor ve devam ediyor
biz internette bir şey üretmekten
durumu
Zaten de güzel şeyler mesela
Vikipedia var değil mi veya bizde Ekşi
Sözlük var yani içeriğini sen ben biz
yazıyoruz ve oluşturuyoruz burada çok
güçlü bir üretim biçimi hakikaten
Önümüzdeki şekil verecek üretim şekli bu
ortak akıl diyoruz yani Mesela bir
hakikaten çok komik ya benim belki
kendime mizah ederim yani benim hayatım
boyunca bulamayacağım 100 tane esprisi
yapıyor bir günde çıkıyor yani
yakalayamıyorsunuz ya
Dolayısıyla bu Biz bütün enerjimizi
Aslında bu tarafa yaymalıyız yani
bulduğumuz internette bulduğumuz
fikirlerin Aslında herkesten nem alana
herkesin ufak ufak şeyler yaparak
katkıda bulunup dev şeyler yarattığı bir
platforma doğru yürümeliyiz Dolayısıyla
dünyayı güzelleştirecek olan şey
teknoloji değil İnsan şimdi insan
deyince motorsiklet nereden geldi
konusuna şey yapayım şimdi ben bu
motorda 6 yıl önce böyle bir motorsiklet
aldım ilk iş Tabii ki hemen girdim
internetten motorum var bakalım
motosiklet motorsiklet sürme
tekniklerini öğreneyim dedim ve
motorsiklet sürüş teknikleri madde biri
gördüm ya daha madde 2 yıl kaç yıldır
bakmıyorum maddi bir diyor ki insan
baktığı yere gider hakikaten motorsiklet
öyle bir şey ki hani öyle direksiyonu
çevir topla falan yok motorsiklette
motosiklette böyle bir yere bakıyorsunuz
oraya gidiyorsunuz
ev başına çarpmayayım çarpıyorsunuz Yani
evet
ama o kadar da güzel maddeleri yazmış ki
adam Yani bin cümlenin üstüne git ya
şimdi özellikle eğitimde
Her insan çok değerli Her insan çok
değerli olduğu için herkes de başka yere
gidiyor ve İnanın ben eğer akademisyen
olduysam herkes olabilir ben çok kötü
bir öğrenciydim gerçekten kötü bir
öğrenciydim ama ben olayım diye oraya
doğru git her zaman ister istemez oraya
gidiyorsunuz ve hayat size oraya
götürüyor ve bu gerçekleşiyor Yani o
anlamda kendinize kesin güvenim ve bunu
şöyle bir alakası yok çok çalışmayın
Tabii ki çok çalışmalısınız onu zaten
herkes yapar
bir şey için çok çalışırsın Neyse
bu insan bir baktığı yere gider şey
açısından çok önemli şimdi Benim
öğrencilerim var
buradaki arkadaşa birlikte
veriliyor bir yıl fizik dersi alıyoruz
Rauf bir öğretmen ve sonuç 3
3 aynı şekilde sizde oluyor ve size
diyor diyelim Gökhan'a da küçük geliyor
ikimiz de
alır şimdi Gökhan bambaşka bir insan
değişkenler o kadar fazla ki ya bambaşka
bir insan ben ikimiz beraber aynı
durumda Bir uzay gemisinde zor durumda
benim
ben özellikle yazarının ilk yıllarında
genç yazarların en büyük problemi 30
tane reklam filmi için 4 sayfa
getirmesidir kompozisyon yazar Düşünsene
öğrenci başına Ben 4 sayfa Okuyorum yani
bir 50 kişi yaptığınızda
Hani okuduğum şey mantıklı olsun onun
gibi
ödevde de değişik bir durum var not da
çok saçma geliyor bana o anlamda şimdi
öğrenci öğrenmek diye bir laf var
Ben daha çok bu işten Bu ilişkiden
öğrencinin faydalandığından emin değilim
yani ben daha çok faydalanıyorum Çünkü
bir kere Onların hepsi benim için Hedef
kitle hepsini tanıyorum bu çok önemli
Hepsi farklı farklı yönleri giden bir
sürü insan tanıyor onların hepsi birden
gece gündüz beni düşünseler bir şey
öğrenecek
yani perspektifinden hayata bakacaklar
bu da aslında az
şimdi bu arkadaşı şey yapalım Bu çocuk
Burak Reis İlkokulu'nda okudu bu da
şimdi Londra'da Robin
Ondan sonra İkisi de çok güzel bu arada
yani bunu kesinlikle söylemek istiyorum
Burak Reis İlkokulu ve öğretmen o kadar
güzel
ne kadar yaz tatilinde Kapı çaldı
biliyor açtım öğretmen gelmiş Evet böyle
iki ay sonra falan Ondan sonra
defnelerde çok özledim dedim
çok eğlenceli çünkü biz biraz akdenizli
olduğu için her şeyi sıcak sıcak
çözüyoruz orada da çok acayip bir şey bu
yıl karnesi geldiğinde
4,5 sayfa yazı yazmış öğretmen çocuk
hakkında
ya da şunu yapar not yemin ediyorum not
gelmedi önüme Defne yalan söylediği
zaman şunları yapıyor Ben Örneğin ben
kendim babası olarak o kadar yazamam
yani 4 sayfa ya 4 sayfa yazmak için o
çocukla bir şey yaşaması lazım yani 3
değil
Öbürüne de 3 Öbürüne de 5 Ya bu çok
yanlış bir yol bence bilmiyorum ama
öğrenciyi anlamaya çalışmak bir kere
insan öğretmenin çok şeyi katıyor ben
çok eğleniyorum yani neyse
bizim böyle saçma sapan bu dijital
konusunda şey yapacağım şöyle yürüyen
bir ilişkimiz var
bütün gün konuşuyorsun çocuk bazen oyun
oynarken beni unutuyor orada
izliyorum falan Neyse
yani eğlenceli bir durum geçen
konuşuyoruz o kadar artık zamanlarda yer
mekan eskisi tamamen kayboldu ki geçen
gün konuşuyoruz
Başıma bir iş gelse felç olsam falan
bana nasıl bakacaklarında dair çok iyi
fikirler elde edindim çünkü birden Eyvah
yemek yandı diye bıraktı beni ben şimdi
böyle duvara bakıyorum Fix anlarsa
İçeriden ses geliyor Anne babamı getir
diyor o dedi Kalk kendin aldı
Neyse Yani sonuç itibariyle FaceTime ve
bunun gibi skype gibi şeyler O kadar çok
hayatımızın içinde ki öğrenci öğretmen
ilişkisini de tamamen değiştiriyor
mesela şu bizim
öğrencilerin mezuniyet projelerini
dinlediğimiz gün arada birkaç öğretmen
var Bakın bu da bir öğretmen warwick
Üniversitesi
fikirleri dinliyor berbatta söylüyor
istersek öğretmenin sesini kısabiliyoruz
yani
ama sonuçta o da bizimle yani bu çok
önemli bir
Çünkü öğrenci öğrenmek yani benden
teknik bilgi nedir ki yani dışarıda sıra
beklemeyen bir insan var bir sıfır
bilgisayar mantığıyla amanar mamalar yok
sıra beklemiyorum ama çünkü bilmem ne
var Acelem var biz bunları öğretiyoruz
Hadi sıra beklememek bir sıfır diye
bakımında sıfırdır
Hayallerinin peşinden koşmak iyi bir
şeydir Bir biz bunları öğretmemiz
gerekiyordu Kurnaz ve uyanık olmak
aslında çok iyi bir şey değildir Öyle
öğretmemiz gerekiyor ya da birlik olmak
iyi bir şeydir insan öldürmelik kötü bir
şey olduğunu yardımı sever olmanın da
iyi bir şey olduğunu öğretmemiz gerek
insanlar liderler toplumlar baktıkları
yere gidiyorlar
dünyayı daha iyi bir yer haline
getirebilecek kadar özgüveni yüksek iyi
öğrenciler yetiştirmemiz gerektiğini
düşünüyorum teşekkür ederim